monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mes chers collègues il me
revient le triste honneur de prendre la
parole pour prononcer l'éloge funèbre de
notre collègue marielle de sarnez
emporté au début de l'année le 13
janvier dernier par une leucémie
foudroyante
prononcé son éloge peut paraître simple
car tous ici nous connaissions ses
talents ses engagement son dévouement au
bien public et à l'urgence européenne
pour reprendre le titre de l'un de ses
livres
les années loges qu'ils soient funèbres
cela paraît presque un non sens car rien
n'était moins funèbre que son
tempérament saône être même
femme de conviction toujours active
toujours ardente
marielle de sarnez était la vitalité
personnifier le mouvement incarné et dix
mois après sa disparition
sonam de combattante semble toujours
défié la fatalité
fille de résistant
marielle de sarnez avait chevillée au
corps le goût de la liberté la passion
du débat démocratique
la volonté de faire avancer ses idées
sans jamais sacrifier au conformisme
elle n'était pas seulement centriste
mais centrale au centre de nos débats au
point nodal des préoccupations qui sont
les nôtres elle avait consacré sa vie à
faire émerger un espace politique
nouveau et libre aussi légitime et
reconnu que la droite et la gauche et
avec ti droite et gauche pouvaient se
rencontrer pour parler imaginer
construire oui elle fut pionnière
en un temps où la bipolarité semblait la
norme elle qui cherchait à réunir plutôt
qu'à exclure
le centre qu'elle désirait n'était pas
un moyen terme un marché hésitant et
ondoyant mais une vraie cause en portant
de vrais combats le centre selon
marielle de sarnez emprunté à la droite
la droiture à la gauche la générosité au
gaullisme de son père l'amour de la
france et un démocratie chrétienne
l'idée européenne
synthèse audacieuse qui fut sa marque
quarante ans durant
la politique marielle de sarnez avait
connu dès l'enfance puisque son père
était le chef de cabinet de roger frey
ministre du général de gaulle pourtant
elle ne voulut pas être une héritière
rompant avec les traditions d'une
famille issue de la noblesse dans pire à
lycéenne s'élance dans le pari à des
bulles ition de mai 68 puis elle cherche
à assurer son indépendance matérielle en
travaillant la politique
ce fut donc par la petite porte qu'elle
y entra pour un simple emploi de
secrétariat en 1973 à 22 ans la voici au
sein des jeunes giscardiens
dans l'effervescence des de ces années
70 elle ne veut ni conservatisme ni
gauchisme mais s'enthousiasme à l'idée
d'un président jeune qui modernise la
france elle est payée de ses efforts en
1974 quand la victoire de son candidat
se traduit par la création d'un
secrétariat d'état à la condition
féminine le droit de vote à 18 ans ou le
renforcement des droits de l'opposition
autant d'innovations qui satisfont sa
quête réformatrice
durant cette mémorable campagne elle
rencontre françois bayrou avec qui elle
fera chemin pour le centre pour l'europe
pour ses idées qu'ils ont en partage et
qu'ils feront avancer ensemble
je sais la douleur de notre ancien
collègue depuis ce jour en trop ou son
alter ego lui fit trop tôt enlevée
il a connu militante députée européenne
élue locale ministres députés
enfin est d'emblée présidente de
commission entre temps elle aura
accompagné comme conseillère puis
directrice de cabinet au ministère de
l'éducation nationale de 1993 à 1997
ensuite comme secrétaire général du
groupe udf à l'assemblée nationale de
1997 à
1998 député européenne à partir de 1999
conseillère de paris à partir de 2001
elle dirige la campagne présidentielle
de françois bayrou en 2002 puis celle de
2007 et 2012
cofondatrice et vice-présidente du
modèle elle devient en 2009 la
secrétaire générale du parti démocrate
européen
ses yeux clairs observe avec acuité un
monde en pleine mutation
dans lequel les vieux clivages s'estompe
et vieilles dictatures s'effondre elle
qui croient en l'europe en la démocratie
à lui ne paie résonné entre nations
raisonnable elle se passionne pour
l'ukraine et sa révolution orange la
couleur même qui était en france celle
du mouvement démocrate orange comme le
soleil levant orange comme la fusion des
métaux des idéaux telle était sa nuance
ardeur et complexité confondues la
recomposition politique de 2017 ne s'est
pas fait sans elle la vend l'un de ses
rares échecs dix ans plus tôt
dans la 11e circonscription de paris
elle obtient plus de 40% des suffrages
au premier tour et plus de
63,5 % au second
sa connaissance des dossiers européens
et internationaux la désigne tout
naturellement à la présidence de notre
commission des affaires étrangères où
elle brille de tous ses feux
le drame syrien le break site et bientôt
la crise du courant navires us mobilise
la militante passionnée qu'elle est
restée la crise migratoire la préoccupe
et elle préside la mission d'information
sur les migrations
surtout cette convaincu
savait aussi écouter les convictions des
autres
respecter et respectueuse soucieuse de
diriger équitablement les débats
marielle de sarnez c'est une grande
présidente de commission
unanimement apprécié pour ce mélange
d'entregent et autorités dont elle avait
le secret ceux là même qui combattent et
ses idées apprécié sa personne la
dignité qui émanait d'elle l'intégrité
de sa parole quand elle disparu tous lui
rendirent hommage constatant à quel
point elle allait manquer à notre
commission à notre assemblée à la
république toute entière
c'est donc avec émotion
avec chagrin que je salue la mémoire de
la grande dame de l'europe qui siégea
parmi nous son exemple
son courage sa détermination jusqu'au
combat final contre la maladie nous les
saluons
puisqu'il était indissociable de la
marielle que nous avons connus
enthousiaste volontaire toujours en
mouvement
dans nos souvenirs dans nos coeurs
elle demeurera vivante dans notre
hémicycle elle nous manque est ce
l'absence nous peine autant qu'elle nous
oblige
l'assemblée nationale se souviendra
d'elle de sa loyauté et de la profondeur
de son engagement à ses enfants si
important pour elle et dont elle était
si fier à sa famille que je salue à ses
amis à ses compagnons de militantisme à
ses collaborateurs au nom de tous les
députés de l'assemblée nationale et un
moment personnel je présente mes
condoléances attristées
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
la disparition de marielle de sarnez
après un long combat contre la maladie
a suscité une émotion profonde et un
hommage partagé bien au delà de sa
famille politique
car marielle de sarnez suscitait le
respect de tous
elle ne recherchait pas la lumière
mais elle s'affirmait naturellement par
son talent par la force de ses
convictions
et de son caractère par la cohérence de
sa pensée
elle vit les y est toujours
l'engagement au service des idées
au service des valeurs à la recherche
des postes et les honneurs
c'est ce droit au sens pour reprendre le
titre évocateur d'un essai politique
fondateur qu'elle entendait offrir à ses
concitoyens
attaché à convaincre
et certainement pas à plaire ou à
séduire par dessus tout
marielle de sarnez représentaient le
contraire de la politique spectacle de
la quête du superficiel de la dictature
de l'immédiateté
jamais elle n'a tutoyé la compromission
toujours elle a veillé à ramener les
choses à l'essentiel
c'était une femme entière qui parfois
rencontré des oppositions mais qui
toujours à n'imposer
elle n'emprunte est ni les sentiers
battus ni les voie de la facilité
ce qui la rendait apte à relever tous
les défis comme celui ci bien réussie de
diriger le cabinet du ministre de
l'éducation nationale
avec le parcours si peu académique qui
était le sien
formidable intuition du ministre de
l'époque
elle savait parfaitement à la fois être
une organisatrice nez soucieuse du
détail et de la mise en oeuvre est porté
et incarner l'idéal qui guidera toute sa
vie politique
un idéal à la fois à puiser dans notre
histoire et d'une profonde modernité
celui d'une force politique central et
centristes
suffisamment puissante pour résister à
l'écartèlement partisans et suffisamment
charpenté
pour ne pas céder aux idées fausse des
marchands de slogans et de solutions
faciles dans les dérives sont toujours
un danger pour les peuples démocratiques
une force politique suffisamment
consciente d'elle-même de son identité
de sa pensée et de son implantation au
coeur même de la nation pour accepter de
composer des majorités d'idées
par delà les frontières partisanes et
les réflexes claniques
une force politique centrale à laquelle
elle a cru viscéralement depuis toujours
très vite un effet elle s'engage
derrière la candidature de valérie
giscard d'estaing à l'élection
présidentielle de 1974
l'homme qui voulait rassembler deux
français sur trois ne pouvait remporter
l'adhésion et l'enthousiasmé de celle
qui a toujours affirmé que ceux qui
rapprochait nos concitoyens étaient bien
plus fort que ce qui les divise est
message d'une étonnante modernité
c'est donc tout naturellement qu'en
1978 elle participe à la création de
l'udf qui a pour vocation de
rassembler toutes les familles jusque-là
désuni qui se réclamait du centre et du
centre droit des familles politiques
héritière d'un riche passé
et qui se reconnaissaient dans le
libéralisme économique autant que dans
le personnalisme de la démocratie
chrétienne ou dans le projet européen
des pères fondateurs
le succès fut au rendez vous car ce
jeune parti rassemble à plus de 21% des
voix aux élections législatives de 1978
que tous les commentateurs jugent est
alors perdue pour la majorité de
gouvernement
cette leçon de sa propre vie
marielle de sarnez de l'oubliera jamais
notamment aux côtés de françois bayrou
avec qui elle allait tisser un
engagement politique exigeant en même
temps qu'une amitié profonde et durable
c'est avec cette même conviction que
marielle de sarnez à participer à la
refondation de l'udf en
1998 qui permit au centre politique
d'éviter
l'effacement lors des élections
législatives de 2002 et d'obtenir près
de 19% des voix aux élections
présidentielles de 2007 à chacune de ces
étapes marielle de sarnez avait défendu
bec et ongles l'identité la liberté et
l'indépendance
de sa famille politique et de ses
convictions c'est pour la renforcer
encore davantage qu elle participa à la
fondation du modem dont je tiens à
saluer tout particulièrement dans cet
instant de recueillement les membres
présents dans cet hémicycle
et lors de cette mandature
marielle de sarnez a pu déployer ses
grandes qualités de parlementaires
notamment vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président à la tête de la commission des
affaires étrangères telles a marqué de
son empreinte si personnelle qui ne
laissait personne indifférent
c'est là qu'est venue la frappe et la
maladie une maladie qui ne lui a laissé
aucune chance
alors même qu'elle n'affrontait avec une
dignité et une force morale dont nous
avons tous été ici même mais aussi bien
au-delà les témoins ému
marielle de sarnez se battait pour ses
enfants
justine et augustin et ses petits
enfants qu'elle aimait par dessus tout
qu'elle ne croyait pas devoir quitter si
tôt mais qu'elle voulait surtout en mère
exemplaire
protéger des souffrances de sa propre
disparition
je veux en cet instant et salué avec
émotion et avec affection au nom du
gouvernement et en mon nom personnel
tout comme françois bayrou d'enjeux
c'est l'indicible peine
avec marielle de sarnez de centre a
perdu une figure longtemps discrète mais
que chacun d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier politique a reconnu comme
centrale
plus que tout autre
marielle aurait voulu que la vie
continue que le combat pour l'espérance
pour la justice pour l'humanisme est
pour la paix entre les peuples notamment
grâce à une europe puissante que ce
combat soit plus fort que tous
puissent
sa clairvoyance son intégrité son
opiniâtreté et son courage nous espérer
longtemps
en mémoire de notre collègue disparu
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vous demande d'observer une minute de
silence
si la séance est suspendue